in the whole history of fake news
there's never been a more fake piece of
news than the New York Times story about
the Russians paying the Taliban to kill
American soldiers for a start the idea
that the resistance to foreign
occupation in Afghanistan needs paying
well that's a bit out of date the last
people to pay for resistance in
Afghanistan was not Russia about the
United States of America throughout the
1980s billions of dollars in money and
material weapons and propaganda support
was poured in by the United States
taxpayer into the father's or older
brothers of the Taliban and the purpose
was not to kill American soldiers but to
kill Russian soldiers thousands of whom
they did kill you might call it a bounty
a dollar bounty for every Russian head
brought in but the Afghans have been
resisting foreign occupation for
centuries if not millennia from
Alexander the Great right up to Donald
Trump not great the Afghan people have
never accepted the foreign occupation of
their country you can ask the histories
of the British army itself which was
three times sent packing by the Afghan
resistance the Afghan people will not
accept foreign soldiers on their land
and never have and they don't need
anybody in Moscow to pay them but the
reality is this story which was planted
by sections of the United States
intelligence services in The New York
Times was then spread across the whole
world despite the fact it was completely
baseless and had no evidence attached to
it at all it was a fact free story and
is now completely disputed by the
intelligence chief of the United States
himself they said the president was
briefed on this fake news story but in
fact he was never briefed because the
intelligence services chiefs themselves
knew that the story was completely
baseless the question that arises
therefore is why was the story planted
well we now know because the Democrats
in Congress have now tabled obstacles to
Donald Trump's plan to withdraw American
soldiers from the disaster of
Afghanistan just in case you've
forgotten we invaded Afghanistan Britain
and the United States and one or two
other European countries
as long ago as 2001 or 19 years ago the
first world war lasted four years the
second world war lasted six years that's
10 years in total we'd been in
Afghanistan almost 20 years almost twice
as long and have achieved absolutely
nothing all the blood that was spilled
the blood of our own soldiers the blood
of American soldiers but overwhelmingly
of course the blood of Afghan civilians
has all been shed entirely in vain the
political situation in Afghanistan today
is exactly what it was when all of this
began if the foreign forces were through
from the country the Taliban would be
back in control before you could say
Jack Robinson and they didn't need
president Putin's rubles in order to
motivate them to do so and when the
Taliban are back in power all the
parents of all the soldiers that we lost
there will be asking what was all of
that for so just remember it wasn't the
Russians that were paying the Islamist
fanatics in Afghanistan it was the
Americans